you ready for this I'll ever be
it will kill
the U.S army officer sword my name is
Tyler Hackbarth I'm 32 years old and I
was an E5 Sergeant for six years in the
Army I think fast react quickly and my
ability to do a lot of different
techniques I think is going to give me
an edge above the other Smiths the U.S
army officer saber has adorned the dress
uniforms up the top grass for over a
century but its predecessors are as old
as America itself
since the establishment of the first
Continental Army by the second
continental congress in June of 1775
American officers have been carrying
their swords into battle as Firearms
slowly replace swords in combat the
ceremonial officer saber was unveiled In
1902 though shorter and more delicately
curved this highly decorated weapon
descends from the fierce battle swords
of the U.S Cavalry today the army
officer saber remains a crowd pleaser at
military ceremonies weddings and parades
U.S naval officers sword my name is Lee
Crawford I was an operation specialist
at in class in the Navy I was in a bad
accident in 2015 where I was burnt over
30 of my body I was diagnosed with PTSD
and an aversion to fire that I had to
overcome and bladesmithing helped me do
that
for over 250 years the United States
naval officer sword has been a
distinguished and integral piece of
uniform for Navy personnel both ornate
and functional the weapon is often
engraved and features a lightweight
straight blade that was key for melee
combat aboard crowded vessels its Sleek
design was also instrumental in defense
featuring a knuckle boat guard to cover
the hand although the officer's sword
underwent several design changes and was
eventually suspended from combat
operations it is still worn in
ceremonies as a symbol of Naval
Authority
thank you
so my plant is going to be to start out
with a nice 25 plus layer Billet of
Damascus
the Damascus is a risk but as long as my
blade does perform as I expect it to my
Damascus is going to be that thing that
puts me over the top I've got my stack
of 1084 right here then I've got my
stack of 15 and 20 here
ready to rock and roll and get this into
the forge
I made a log splitter press so that's
given me 22 tons of squish squish
probably cut this into about four bars
which will put us at uh
108 layers restacked
and we'll get them over to the welder
it's time to quench
got a real real slight warp in the end I
think that's something I can grind out
the file skates
I rounded off a piece of wood to help me
develop that curve in the guard that's a
good start we're going to bring out that
Damascus
the most rewarding part about making
Damascus is going into the acid I'm just
110 pleased with it the contrast is
great the pattern is awesome
I can't wait to see this blade tested by
the judges hopefully I can hear
it will kill
the sword I'm making for the challenge
is the naval officer sword first thing
I'm going to do today is use my rotary
tool and hand grind in my Fuller
[Music]
for a hand puller
can't ask for much better
blades ready to be quenched
the one thing you always think about is
don't snap this is the moment don't have
a warp Snaps are fatal warps are
critical but can be fixed
pull it out
oh
it's hard but it's got a bow
to The Jig I have to get it in my
straining jig to see if we can get that
pulled out let's hope it straightened it
if not we gotta go through that whole
thing again
pick it up look down it bam we got a
straight blade all right it's time to
move on to the handle material I set up
the Micarta handles by cutting them
rough shape to fit the handle
drill the holes like that I think I need
to get the pommel so when I do make the
guard
and knuckle bow I know where to end it
so I need the pommel next
it's pretty blade heavy and it's going
to need a big chunk of the brass to be
able to balance that out done
all right soldiers your weapons look
beautiful but were they born to kill to
find that out I'm going to take your
weapons and deliver slashes and thrust
on this ballistics dummy Tyler you're up
first you ready for this ready it's all
over me
foreign
I knew him well
all right Tyler this Edge is sharp I
mean just pulling out of that look how
deeply it cut this ballistics dummy now
in cutting the spine and the jaw it took
a little bit of glinting but no major
chips stayed straight and most of all
it will kill thank you
all right Lee it's your turn you ready
yes sir let's do this
that's a lot of hog to go through with a
skinny blade I'm pretty nervous
foreign
the handle construction is comfortable
your Edge not one single glint or
rolling your tip punctures and cuts on
the way out and overall sir
it will kill yes
yes
blade Smiths welcome to the strength
test
to test the strength of your blade and
the overall construction of your Sabers
I'm going to beat them violently into
these helmets like they were being worn
by my mortal enemy now I'm not really
concerned about what your Savor does to
the helmets or the dummy I want to see
what the helmet and dummy are going to
do to your Sabers Tyler you're gonna go
first you ready yep
[Laughter]
furman's blade takes a bend and mine
could be next could go anywhere I don't
know what's going to happen
[Music]
Tyler is a beast
you got some chipping on the edge I can
catch my nail on I don't see any
pulls or delaminations in your steel
still in one piece it's still sharp good
job thank you awesome dude all right
gentlemen it's time for the strength
test the dreaded Flex test
[Music]
to test the strength of your blade I'll
be bending it in both directions
up to that red point you ready for this
yes sir this is the strength test this
is what is really going to push our
blades
it's a sink or swim moment
the longest five seconds of my life
but I'm holding my breath and just
praying that it holds together
[Music]
nice job Lynn their blade is still same
shape and started it that's impressive
thank you sir really good
foreign
forged in fire war of weapons
[Music]